autre manifestation autorisée par la
police la préfecture de police
aujourd'hui mobilisation contre les
violences policières et en particulier
pour lamine dieng ce jeune franco
sénégalais de 25 ans est décédé en 2007
lors d'une interpellation de police on a
appris en début de semaine par la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme que
l'état français allait verser 145 1000
euros aux proches de la victime afin de
solder toutes poursuites dans cette
affaire
voyez les précisions sur place de notre
reporter thomas gonnet une longue marche
pour rendre hommage à lamine dieng 13
ans après le décès de ce jeune homme de
25 ans dans le 20e arrondissement lors
de son interpellation par la police
treizième année dommage pour lamine
dieng et une manifestation plus générale
sur les violences policières d'autres
familles endeuillées était également
présente au côté de la famille de ce
jeune homme de 25 ans je propose
d'écouter d'ailleurs la soeur de lamine
dieng ramata diakité au micro de sint à
l'auberge la france a accepté de verser
les indemnités que la cour avait fixé et
donc nous de notre côté
sur conseils de nos avocats nous avons
aussi accepté donc ses règlements alors
pourquoi ce choix parce que c'est un
aveu de culpabilité est l'aveu de
culpabilité vient pour moi c'est encore
plus fort que la condamnation est donc
voilà pour un résultat identique
on ne voulait pas encore comment dire a
passé trois ans nous procédions cinq ans
de procédure pour aboutir sur le même
résultat
donc c'est pour cela que nous avons
accepté et donc la décision et public on
trouve l'arrêt sur la côte sur le site
de la cod h et nous nous sommes libres
de communiquer sur cet arrêt donc voilà
ils n'ont pas acheté notre silence
bien au contraire plusieurs centaines de
personnes étaient réunies donc pour
marcher dans les rues de paris et faire
entendre des revendications notamment
celle de mettre fin à certaines
techniques employées par les forces de
l'ordre lors des interpellations on
pense notamment à cette clé
d'étranglement qui fait polémique depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines
beaucoup de personnes donc rassembler et
au milieu de ce cortège il y avait aussi
des
les jaunes qui avaient de quoi témoigné
en ce qui concerne les violences
policières on a notamment vu jérôme on
dresse au sein de ce cortège d'autres
actions sont à attendre désormais
puisque vous savez depuis plusieurs
semaines les manifestations contre les
violences policières se tiennent assez
régulièrement dans les rues de la
capitale